you may not be familiar with the name
Jamie Lopez I certainly wasn't until
this week when she died but her death is
worth discussing whether you'd heard of
her or not before uh before now Lopez
was the founder of a well-known beauty
salon called baby doll Beauty Couture
and she was the star of a reality show
called super size salon now as the title
of the show indicates the salon was
focused on providing services to obese
people proudly billing itself as the
world's first plus-sized Salon Lopez
herself was a plus size model and as
media reports about her death have
characterized her she was a quote Fierce
advocate of fat acceptance and body
positivity her show and her public brand
centered around the basic message that
everyone is beautiful no matter their
size and we should accept and celebrate
all body types
she was only 37 when she died this week
they've not released a confirmed cause
of death but the Daily Mail and other
outlets report that she was suffering
from heart complications among other
potential
maladies now
there's a reason why I bring this all up
but before I flesh that out it may be
enlightening to watch A Brief sneak peek
of the super-sized Salon show which was
posted on WE TV's YouTube channel a few
months ago to promote the show and the
problems we're going to talk about are
all Illustrated I think very explicitly
in this clip and here it is
love beautiful things it's just a part
of me I've been doing makeup since I was
13 years old I just have always just
loved making women feel beautiful oh my
God
I'm a social media influencer in the
plus size community
I manifest every single day Jamie in the
big girl Community is like an icon she's
very beautiful confident she is really a
goat Jamie's just a fabulous the Amazon
she loves to just see people happy
you're gorgeous thank you
I am the owner and Creator and the hbic
of baby doll Beauty Couture welcome
today
[Music]
my dream was to create the first ever
all-inclusive salon by plus size girls
four plus size girls you're in good
hands society makes you hate yourself if
you don't look a certain way and I am
damn determined to change that
baby doll is about embracing who you are
yes girl yes you might have fat ass
people come to your salon but you don't
have a plus size Salon when cheers for
big asses like ours all this
it's for all it is
so it's a message that a sermon that we
hear all the time in our culture we
should not make obese people feel bad
about themselves everyone is beautiful
fat is beautiful everyone should be
accepted all weights all sizes
um indeed fatness is now its very own
identity group there is as we heard in
the clip there a community a Sisterhood
of fat women and this community deserves
to be included and tolerated
even as they kill themselves in front of
us
now the tragic reality here is that
Jamie Lopez was apparently trying to
lose weight towards the end of her life
and her heavy issue had reached 846
pounds and found herself uh unable she
was bed bound she was unable to support
her own weight enough to move around
without assistance and and she had
apparently dropped a significant amount
of weight I think maybe like half her
body weight but was still you know 400
pounds extremely morbidly obese and it
would seem
the damage had been done because our
bodies are not meant to carry around
that kind of weight our bones our
internal organs our you know our hearts
none of it was built to support hundreds
of pounds of excess fat
that's why morbid obesity will kill you
it's not an if here there's no if it's
not like a maybe that the only thing
that will stop a morbidly obese person
from dying of their obesity
is if they die from something else first
or if they lose the weight before the
clock Runs Out
neither those two things happen and they
will die of obesity will 100 of the time
um Jamie Lopez was one of thousands upon
thousands of obese people every year who
perish from the condition the clock runs
out something like a quarter of a
million Americans die from obesity
related causes every year which makes up
ten percent of all obesity related
deaths globally in spite of the fact
that the US only comprises four percent
of the global population
now Lopez may have tried to lose weight
at the end but she was a part of and a
victim of also a movement
that tells obese people that they don't
need to lose weight unless they want to
like if you want to then go ahead but
but you don't need to
the fat acceptance movement body
positivity has killed countless people
in this country
and now it's killed one of its more
prominent advocates
and that's the point we should be
focusing on this is not about exploiting
certainly not about making light of a
woman's tragic death it's about
confronting the fact that the fat
acceptance Movement typified by nearly
everything you heard in that promotional
clip is a suicidal ideology I mean it is
a death cult fat acceptance is a death
cult it's one of the most dangerous
ideas in the world and that's not an
exaggeration
at a time when we're so focused on the
alleged harms inflicted by you know
quote-unquote misinformation
it's probably time that we start
thinking about the misinformation that
tells people like Jamie Lopez and so
many others that morbid suicidal
self-destructive obesity is something to
be celebrated
that it's beautiful
Lopez will not be the only body
positivity influencer to die in early
death they will almost all suffer the
same fate fat acceptance became a
mainstream Phenomenon with its own slate
of Advocates and stars and influencers
in just the past 10 years or so we're
reaching the point now where we might
expect to start seeing many of them
succumb to their obesity
but then again if 280 000 obesity
related deaths every single year isn't
enough for a wake-up call I imagine that
every single quote fat acceptance
celebrity could die
and that wouldn't be enough either
still whether people want to hear it or
not we need to start speaking some hard
truths truths truth such as this
obesity
is not beautiful
it is it is not beautiful for the same
reason that we don't call alcoholism
beautiful or anorexia beautiful if
somebody engages in self-harm and cuts
themselves we don't say that the scars
are beautiful if a crazy guy
self-immolates we don't stand around the
fire talking about how pretty the flame
is
it's not because we hate the alcoholic
or we hate the anorexic or we hate the
cutter or we hate the self-immolator
exactly the opposite we love them and
therefore we hate what is destroying
them you should hate the things
that destroy
or threaten to destroy the people that
you love
including obesity
now there some people will undoubtedly
criticize me for talking about this
right now only a couple days after the
woman died they'll say that it's
exploitative disrespectful
and yet if she was a member of the
alcoholism is beautiful movement and
then died of liver disease stemming from
alcohol consumption we would all agree
that it would be absurd to not talk
about the connection what else are you
going to talk about to ignore it would
be ludicrous even Reckless
the same applies here
now is not only an acceptable time but
the most important time to point out
that there is nothing beautiful about
self-destruction
there's nothing beautiful about an early
grave these are ugly horrid things they
are brutal and grotesque
fat acceptance as a movement as an
ideology is brutal and grotesque it is a
celebration of death
we shouldn't just oppose it and disagree
with it we should hate it we should hate
it for the deadly Sinister propaganda
that it is
now I think the problem
in part at least
is that we've bought into this this lie
that lifestyles are sacrosanct
right however person however a person
chooses to live is automatically above
reproach simply because they're living
that way
to criticize a lifestyle
such as a lifestyle of overeating
gluttony lethargy laziness that is to
suggest that a person should live
differently from how they're currently
living but that's the ultimate heresy in
our culture
because for us the the only thing you
are meant to say or that you can say
about a person's lifestyle is that it's
courageous and inspirational
right we're at a point now where all
lifestyles are Courageous by default
simply to live however you feel like
living is an act of Courage
whereas to live differently from how you
feel like living to make purposeful
changes with the intention of becoming a
different sort of person is somehow an
act of
self-betrayal
and to encourage others to live
differently is bigotry Prejudice hatred
but this is all nonsense
and it is getting people killed
lots of people every single day
when will enough be enough that's the
question
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow God Speak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you